[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute nichts
barbara hahlweg
guten abend und willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem mittwoch
an meiner seite ist wieder die fahne für
den sport hallo schön
und wir haben unter anderem diese themen
für sie
vorfahrt für die ampel grüne und fdp
sprechen schon morgen gemeinsam mit der
spd über eine mögliche koalition
bei cdu und csu wächst der frust
kanzler unter korruptionsverdacht in
österreich steigt der druck auf
sebastian kunz gewaltig die behörden
durchsuchen heute parteizentrale und das
bundeskanzleramt
[Musik]
der nächste deutsche nobelpreis der
chemiker benjamin ist aus mülheim an der
ruhr erhält die wichtigste auszeichnung
der wissenschaft
ein wichtiger schritt zu einer rot grün
gelben regierung ist getan zehn tage
nach der bundestagswahl erklärten heute
erst die grünen und dann die fdp dass
sie erstmals zu dritt mit den
sozialdemokraten sondieren wollen und
zwar schon ab morgen
spd-kanzlerkandidat olaf scholz freut
auch wenn wir es grünen-chef habib
ausdrückt der kiggs noch lange nicht
gegessen ist aus berlin das boot sank
die vor sondierungen sind noch keine 24
stunden beendet da brechen bereits am
morgen die grünen vor ihre botschaft ist
klar sie wollen dreier gespräche mit fdp
und spd nach diesen gesprächen haben wir
uns beraten und sind zu dem schluss
gekommen dass es sinnvoll ist weiter
jetzt vertieft gerade auch mit blick auf
die gemeinsamkeiten die wir in diesem
bilateralen gesprächen feststellen
konnten jetzt mit fdp und spd weiter zu
sprechen eine komplette absage an
jamaika sei das nicht betont auch
fdp-chef lindner parallel gespräche mit
union und grünen allerdings werde es
auch nicht geben wir haben den vorschlag
eines
gesprächs mit der spd angenommen um
gemeinsamkeiten zu prüfen die unser land
nach vorne bringen ich habe herrn scholz
eben in abstimmung mit den grünen
angeboten dass wir bereits morgen zu
einem solchen gespräch zu dritt zusammen
kommen zufriedene gesichter bei der spd
die sozialdemokraten haben von anfang an
den anspruch formuliert die regierung zu
führen die bürgerinnen und bürger seinen
auftrag gegeben eine regierung zusammen
zustande zu bringen auch die aktuellen
umfragen zeigen immer wieder dass das
der wille der bürgerinnen und bürger
dieses landes ist es ist jetzt an uns
das auch umzusetzen
morgen also sollen die ersten richtigen
sondierungen von spd fdp und grünen
beginnen damit sind die weichen gestellt
richtung ampel koalition
die union reagiert höchst
unterschiedlich csu-chef söder wertet
die entscheidung von grünen und fdp als
de facto absage an jamaika
kanzlerkandidat lasche dagegen gibt die
hoffnung nicht auf die union sei weiter
gesprächsbereit dann ja konnten es
bräuchte nun wohl vor allem die und
entschlossenheit bei cdu/csu um
womöglich doch noch eine rolle zu
spielen bei der bildung der nächsten
regierung
davon aber war heute erneut wenig zu
spüren zunächst äußerte sich am mittag
in düsseldorf armin laschet wir haben
signalisiert wir stehen auch zu weiteren
gesprächen bereit aber die entscheidung
mit wem man in welcher reihenfolge
spricht liegt bei fdp und grünen und
deshalb unser respekt für die
entscheidung wir stehen bereit als
gesprächspartner cdu und csu wenig
später hörte sich der tenor aus münchen
jedoch ganz anders an nach seiner erst
gestern dargebotenen charmeoffensive
gegenüber den grünen kann es heute eher
nach abwicklung der jamaika option meine
sehr verehrten damen und turner von
meiner seite schön kontakt
wir haben jetzt endlich klarheit
das heute war eine klare vorfestlegung
von grünen und fdp und de facto eine
absage an jamaika wir bedauern diese
entscheidung ausdrücklich und als habe
man schon abgeschlossen mit der jamaika
option ergänzte der csu landesgruppen
chef eines die kritik gegenüber den
potenziellen partnern grünen und fdp in
vergangenheitsform konjunktiv ich glaube
es wäre jetzt auch ein gutes spiel
gewesen dass man wenn es schon um dreier
konstellationen geht dass man das auch
mal gemeinsam zeigt dass man
zusammensitzt dass man die inhalte auch
gemeinsam diskutiert offensichtlich war
das jetzt so nicht gewünscht
wie sehr jamaika tatsächlich gewünscht
war bei sämtlichen unions protagonisten
dazu gibt es auch nach den viel
diskutierten durchstechereien in berlin
sehr unterschiedliche einschätzungen
fragen wir wieder theo koll in berlin
dazu wie lange kann sich armin laschet
noch halten
das nenne ich aber nur einfache frage
also mein eindruck ist es der
politischen abgrund nicht mehr allzu
weit entfernt ist und dass er sich
täglich weiter nähert bzw von
eilfertigen parteifreunden genährt wird
heute meinte beispielsweise die cdu-vize
klöckner die partei müsse sich
inhaltlich und personell prüfen das sind
ja alles verklausulierte aussagen dass
in der union ein massives aufräumen
bevorstehen dürfte aber noch schütz
laschet die restchance auf jamaika
keiner möchte der der königsmörder sein
und keiner möchte der schuldige sein der
für die union die jamaika option und sei
sie noch so unwahrscheinlich verbindlich
abgesagt hat das hat übrigens auch
markus söder noch nicht auch er hat die
türe für jamaika noch einen kleinen sehr
kleinen spalt offen gelassen vielen dank
für diese einschätzung aus berlin
20 jahre bundeswehr in afghanistan ein
umstrittener einsatz der jetzt
aufgearbeitet werden soll zum auftakt
heute hatte das verteidigungsministerium
eingeladen
93.000 deutsche soldatinnen und soldaten
waren in afghanistan
stationiert viele fragen sich im
nachhinein wofür eigentlich das gilt
noch mehr für die angehörigen der 59
getöteten soldaten aus berlin thomas
reichert die aufarbeitung des längsten
teuersten und verlustreichsten
auslandseinsatz der bundeswehr soll im
konferenz sollen eines berliner hotels
beginnen mit einem versprechen der
ministerin
dass wir es nicht einfach abhaken
sondern dass wir uns einer offenen einer
ehrlichen ja auch an der einen oder
anderen stelle schmerzhaften debatte
stellen damit die nächsten einsätze
besser werden was also ist die lehre aus
afghanistan nun da dort die taliban
wieder herrschen da jene
sicherheitskräfte die von der bundeswehr
jahre trainiert wurden davon gelaufen
sind in der bundeswehr betonte die
erfolge etwa am ende die die
evakuierungs mission aber auch deren
kommandeur tut sich schwer mit einer
bilanz ich bin gespalten ich bin
komplett gespalten weil ich jetzt selber
sicherheitskräfte aufgebaut habe sowohl
armee streitkräfte als auch
polizeikräfte stelle mir deswegen die
frage warum kann ein sicherheitsapparate
so schnell umkippen ohne widerstand
wichtig ist an diesem tag nicht nur der
hierzu gehört sondern auch wer nicht
abgesagt hat der außenminister haben die
abgeordneten des
verteidigungsausschusses auch von der
union das sei kurz nach der wahl der
falsche zeitpunkt
grundsätzlich müssen wir afghanistan
evaluieren übrigens etwas was wir vier
jahre lang von der ministerin uns
erhofft haben von ihr und ihrer
vorgängerin dass es nicht gekommen und
es jetzt so zwischen tür und angel zu
machen halten wir für falsch die
parlamentarier fordern eine ausführliche
aufarbeitung durch den nächsten
bundestag zuvor soll mit einem großen
zapfenstreich vor dem reichstag der
afghanistan einsetzen der nächsten woche
offiziell beendet werden
nach österreich gegen bundeskanzler
sebastian kurz laufen schon ermittlungen
wegen des verdachts der falschaussage
jetzt kommt auch noch der verdacht der
korruption dazu so soll zum beispiel
eine zeitung 2016 geschönte
meinungsumfragen veröffentlicht haben im
gegenzug habe das finanzministerium
anzeigen in millionenhöhe geschaltet
britta hilpert hat details
das hat es in wien noch nie gegeben
hausdurchsuchung im bundeskanzleramt und
auch in der övp parteizentrale so früh
am morgen es gibt keine bilder davon es
geht um den verdacht der untreue und
bestechlichkeit auch sebastian kurz ist
beschuldigt habe auch diesmal sind es
konstruierte vorwürfe wieder mit
derselben systematik es werden einige
sms fetzen aus dem zusammenhang gerissen
es geht um artikel und umfragen der
zeitung österreich aus der zeit als kurz
erst parteivorsitzender und dann kanzler
wurde laut staatsanwaltschaft sollen
seine engsten mitarbeiter inhalte
bestellt und bezahlt haben die kurz
aufstieg begünstigten kurz scheint
mindestens involviert das anbahnen des
geschäfts die geldflüsse und freude über
das ergebnis zeigen chat verläufe in der
akte sobald wir bin ich echt noch nie
gegangen so ein enger mitarbeiter genial
is investment wer zahlt schafft an
sebastian kurz am gleichen tag danke für
österreich heute
angeblich wurde über das
finanzministerium verschleiert
abgerechnet die vorwürfe wiegen schwer
die staatsanwaltschaft sieht tatsächlich
erhärten kann auf welche weise auch
immer dann kann das sehr sehr gefährlich
werden dann ist das ein echter
sprengstoff auch für die koalition
der grüne koalitionspartner hält sich
noch zurück will nur für unabhängige
ermittlungen sorgen das kann dauern aber
bereits freitag soll es eine
sondersitzung im nationalrat geben
misstrauensvotum nicht ausgeschlossen
sechs länder auf dem westbalkan hoffen
schon lange auf einen beitritt zur
europäischen union
doch auf einem gemeinsamen treffen mit
den eu staats und regierungschefs heute
gab es keinen konkreten zeitplan die eu
versprach den ländern wirtschaftshilfe
den milliarden höhe sie sieht jedoch
reformbedarf zum beispiel bei der
rechtsstaatlichkeit einige länderchefs
banken staaten des westbalkans könnten
sich china oder russland zu wenden wenn
sie keine perspektive bekommen
in der ukraine nach kiel dort hat
bundespräsident steinmeier an die
deutschen verbrechen im zweiten
weltkrieg erinnert vor allem an das
massaker von babij jar vor 80 jahren
steinmeier sprach von unsagbarer trauer
und scham der holocaust in babi jar sei
lange nicht angemessen wahrgenommen
worden
1941 hatten die nationalsozialisten in
nur zwei tagen mehr als 33.000 jüdische
zivilisten in der schlucht babij jar
erschossen
wir kommen zum thema corona und schauen
als erstes auf die zahlen innerhalb
eines tages registrierte das
robert-koch-institut 11 1547
neuinfektionen
233 weniger als vergangenen mittwoch die
sieben tage inzidenz ist auf 62 3
gesunken neben corona fürchten experten
diesen herbst auch eine besonders starke
grippewelle umso deutlicher werben das
rk ii und der gesundheitsminister auch
hier für die impfung britta buchholz
am morgen lässt sich der
gesundheitsminister in einer
hausarztpraxis impfung gegen die grippe
das kalkül die krankenhäuser sollen auf
keinen fall mit einer grippewelle
belastet werden denn beides corona und
grippe patienten könnten das
gesundheitssystem zum kollaps bringen
die experten waren gerade ältere
unterschätzten die gefahr einer grippe
würden sich zu selten impfen lassen der
appell bitte lassen sie sich gegen
grippe impfen das ist kein harmloses
fieber sondern es kann insbesondere auch
bei vor erkrankte und bei ältere älteren
einen sehr schweren teilweise auch
tödlichen verlauf nehmen impfstoff sei
genug da das problem der impfmüdigkeit
bei corona löst dies aber alles nicht
zwar sind über 60 prozent der deutschen
geimpft aber die impfquote müsse höher
liegen konkrete lösungsvorschläge
keine besonders im blick auch die kinder
in einigen bundesländern dürfen sie nun
im unterricht die masken abnehmen eine
umstrittene lockerung das rk ii setzt
sich für die masken pflicht ein es gibt
keinen anlass daran zu rütteln dass
schutzmaßnahmen in schulen in kitas und
auch in
alten- und pflegeheim insbesondere das
sind jetzt die 200 arbeitsgruppen über
noch haben dass diese schutzmaßnahmen
nicht aufrechterhalten werden sollten
ganz klar allerdings räumte er auch ein
dass die verläufe bei kindern bisher
überwiegend mild sind impfen als schutz
man kann sich übrigens zeitgleich gegen
die grippe und gegen coop 19 impfen
lassen
beihilfe durch unterlassung so lautete
heute in münster das nüchterne urteil zu
einer tat die selbst die ermittler
fassungslos machte zu sieben jahren und
neun monaten haft verurteilte das
landgericht die mutter eines jungen der
über jahre von mehreren männern
vergewaltigt wurde die 32 jährige habe
von den taten ihres lebensgefährten
gewusst aber nicht gehandelt der
hauptangeklagte war schon im juli zu 14
jahren gefängnis plus
sicherungsverwahrung verurteilt worden
nach dem antisemitismus vorwurf gegen
mitarbeiter eines leipziger hotels hat
die staatsanwaltschaft die ermittlungen
aufgenommen und prüft die gegenseitigen
vorwürfe der jüdische musiker gil ofarim
hatte berichtet er sei wegen eines
davidstern sun seiner kette an der
rezeption nicht bedient worden ein
hotelmitarbeiter hat dagegen anzeige
wegen verleumdung erstattet
gestern abend haben vor dem hotel
mehrere hundert menschen gegen
antisemitismus demonstriert das
hotelmanagement teilte mit zwei
mitarbeiter vorübergehend beurlaubt zu
haben
jubel bei der deutschen forschung nach
dem physik-nobelpreis geht auch der für
chemie nach deutschland und zwar an
benjamin ließ direktor des mülheimer max
planck institut für kohlenforschung der
53 jährige teilt sich die auszeichnung
mit dem gebürtigen schotten david mc
millan tobias häfner über ihre forschung
und über einen künftigen
nobelpreisträger der es erst gar nicht
glauben wollte
kurzurlaub in amsterdam mit gemütlichen
frühstück und plötzlich klingelte bei
benjamin liszt das telefon es ist wahr
der max-planck-forscher aus mülheim
erhält den nobelpreis für chemie
dem display steht schweden und meine
frau sieht ist so gesagt das ist der
anruf aber so als scherz der dann gehe
ich mit dem telefon raus und dann war's
halt der anruf mm und wofür gibt es den
preis wissenschaftlich ausgedrückt für
bahnbrechende forschung zur
asymmetrischen organo katalyse einfacher
übersetzt es geht um katalysatoren aber
nicht wie beim auto wo metalle
autoabgase entschärfen sondern um kleine
organische teilchen die wie ein magier
chemische prozesse in allen lebenslagen
effizienter günstiger und
umweltfreundlicher machen
katalysatoren sind
extrem wichtig als technologie und zwar
eigentlich ob für die herstellung von
quasi allem was uns umgibt die
medikamente die farbstoffe die
riechstoffe
plastik benzin aber noch etwas ist
wichtig etwa bei medikamenten wie zb
eine linke und eine rechte hand können
auch moleküle fast gleich aber
spiegelverkehrt aufgebaut sein und ganz
unterschiedliche funktionen erfüllen im
schlimmsten fall entsteht so zwar
einerseits eine arznei andererseits aber
ein gift liszts verfahren hilft hier
quasi gut und böse besser zu
unterscheiden und übrigens freude am
forschen liegt irgendwie in der gesamten
familie von benjamin ist auch seine
tante hat einen nobelpreis für medizin
ziemlich beeindruckend naja erstmal
durchatmen haben wir gerade gesehen
gerne die deutsche
fußball-nationalmannschaft will mit zwei
erneuten siegen vorzeitig die wm
qualifikation für die endrunde nächstes
jahr perfekt machen freitag steht in
hamburg das spiel gegen israel an drei
tage später in nord mazedonien
inzwischen ist auch der kapitän
startklar in der hamburger arena sind
25.000 fans zugelassen 21.000 karten
sind bereits verkauft nach einem tag
pause ist manuel neuer heute wieder ins
team-training eingestiegen somit konnten
sie fliegt erstmals mit dem gesamten
kader
nach dem neuen punkte start des neuen
bundestrainers soll nun der nächste
entwicklungsschritt folgen man merkt der
überzeugung man merkt natürlich auch die
freude man merkt auch dass wir natürlich
aufgrund der hohen qualität der spieler
auch einen guten konkurrenzkampf haben
und
das ist das allerwichtigste bierhoff
spürt einen positiven geist im dfb-team
gegen rumänien werden wieder die bayern
spiele eine zentrale rolle einnehmen
kimmig und score edgar vor der abwehr
und in der offensive die formstarken
gabri und sunny
nach den antisemitischen vorfällen beim
europakonferenz league spiel zwischen
union berlin und makkabi haifa ist ein
erster mutmaßlicher täter ermittelt
worden der mann soll am vergangenen
donnerstag in einem fanblock des
olympiastadions anhänger des
israelischen meisters angegriffen haben
gegen das clubmitglied wurde jetzt ein
ausschlussverfahren eingeleitet sowie
ein hausverbot verhängt
nochmal berlin hertha bsc lässt seine
ungeimpften spieler die kosten für die
notwendigen pcr kroner tests künftig
selbst zahlen der verein der in der
letzten saison zwischenzeitlich in
quarantäne musste lässt seine profis
sechs mal pro woche testen und ein fest
für alle soll die
fußball-europameisterschaft 20 24 in
deutschland werden in spielorten wie
hamburg münchen oder berlin soll es
genauso bunt und fröhlich zugehen wie
bei der heim-wm 2006 bei einem festakt
in der hauptstadt nahm ok- chef philipp
lahm den em pokal aus den händen des
uefa präsidenten aleksander ceferin
entgegen farbenfroh auch das offizielle
logo für die endrundenspiele die in drei
jahren ausgetragen werden also
vielleicht dann das sommermärchen
2.0
das kreuzbein ist nicht nur für uns
menschen wichtig auch für dinosaurier im
chinesischen lufingen haben forscher
jetzt auch die kreuzbein wirbel dieses
dinos aus der jurazeit ausgegraben die
fossilien dürften grob 145 bis 200
millionen jahre alt sein das kreuzbein
sei so etwas wie das schwere zentrum des
tieres sagen die experten der dino soll
übrigens so ausgesehen haben
fehlen noch die lottozahlen die
gewinnzahlen lauten 3 18 27 29 40 und
die superzahl 2 weitere gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto punkt zdf.de und im
zdf text auf seite 5 157
der regen wird wieder weniger sagt es
sind alle gleich beim wetter und im
heute journal spricht christian sievers
sowohl mit grünen chefin annalena
baerbock als auch mit fdp-chef lindner
wie gehabt um viertel vor zehn machen
sie sich noch einen schönen abend und
bis morgen wenn sie mögen
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter nach dem
historischen extremwetterereignisse
südlich der alpen mit regenmenge eines
ganzen jahr sind 24 stunden in
norditalien verzieht sich nun dieses
tief hier und nimmt den regen mit aber
einige regenwolken erreichen den
südosten deutschlands schauen wir uns
das genau an in der nacht gibt es im
westen viele wolken mit regen oder auch
im süden sonst klart es teilweise auf
und es bildet sich der nebel bei
tiefsten temperaturen von zwei grad in
den östlichen mittelgebirgen und 10 grad
am niederrhein ja und morgen
tagesverlauf vor allem im südosten viele
wolken und regen es ist nicht viel und
das zieht dann auch im tagesverlauf
allmählich südostwärts ab ansonsten nach
nebelauflösung gibt es viel sonnenschein
und vor allem aber nach ganz ganz im
norden und das bei höchsten temperaturen
von 19 grad generell in der nordhälfte
milder als nach süden hin mit zehn grad
am alpenrand und die nächsten tage
während trockener und sonniger wenn sich
der nebel aufgelöst hat zwölf bis 19
grad am freitag ja am samstag vor allem
westen viel sonnenschein und sonntag bei
10 bis 17 grad damit ein schöner amt